peter is with us in Ann Arbor Michigan
hi Peter welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call I
just want to say thank you because your
show has been so helpful to my life
especially when I was in a dark place
bill thank you sure what can I help
Dave I used to work in information
technology and I transitioned into
flipping houses I slipped a couple
houses first house I made a hundred
thousand on second house I made two
hundred thousand I sold I'm doing pretty
pretty good at it except I have a lot of
debt I've been using a lot of debt and I
want to now be debt-free I don't want to
use that but I don't want to pay too
much that off at one time and not have
enough cash flow to continue my business
mm-hmm well I wonder if you have any
tips about that well yeah I have a
friend for instance that had a car
dealership and debt as normal in
flipping houses debt as normal in a car
dealership that's normal if your home
builder and you're doing spec houses
it's a normal thing there but in any of
those you know types of businesses this
kind of an idea will work all he did was
he said well I can't pay off all of this
he was running you know the standard
floor plan you call it were you you know
you run that on your inventory and every
time you sell a car you replace the car
and with more debt you know and so you
just you know you have a basically a
line of credit that you're running the
cars on and off of and so what he
decided to do was at the end of the
first year he wanted to have 25% of his
cars not on the floor plan in other
words debt-free colors sitting on the
lot at the end of second year you wanted
50% of the car sitting on a lot not on
the floor planned third year and you see
where this was going
took him four years of every time he'd
saw a car he'd sent back you know a
quarter on the dollar or a $0.50 on the
dollar or whatever he could set back to
where then he didn't do it I've got a
friend that also is a home builder he's
a third generation
his grandpa did that and they you know
his dad's his dad and his uncles never
borrowed money and
and built big nice expensive homes and
you know did with cash because grandpa
had worked his way up to this point
because once you get enough to do a flip
with cash
you know you increase your margins you
decrease your risk and you know and if
you you know you've made $300,000 on two
deals that would have that battle only
if you didn't need money out of that 300
to eat you know that that 300 would have
bought another house yeah and so you
just work your way towards it maybe the
next deal you do is not dead free but
you say okay two deals later I'm gonna
back down on the size of properties I'm
flipping and I'm gonna crank up and you
know you know take these profits and
roll them back in and you should be able
to pay cash two or three deals later for
your next deal Jinyu I think that the
perfect plan yeah so just you know the
trick is just you're not gonna get there
instantaneously it's going to be a an
incremental process and it feels weird
because you're continuing to actively
borrow money but it's less and less each
time with a game plan of being free soon
we get the noose off your necks and so I
think it's a great plan to flip houses
with cash and and I get there as soon as
I could